[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin ihnen allen guten abend und
mit mir im studio kristin otto und hat
einige fußball kracher im gepäck spätere
zu mehr europa champions league gut amt
wir blicken jetzt auf unseren überblick
krieg in der ukraine der kampf um das
stahlwerk von mario pohl geht weiter und
ukraine präsident zealand skelett
bundespräsident steinmeier nach kiew ein
startschuss für das erste lng terminal
in wilhelmshaven mit flüssigerdgas welt
deutschland unabhängiger von russland
werden
und was für ein wahnsinns spiel real
madrid schlägt manchester city und steht
im finale der fußball champions league
[Applaus]
rund um das belagerte stahlwerk in
mariupol wird weiter gekämpft zur
angeblichen erstürmung des komplexes
durch russische truppen gibt es
widersprüchliche aussagen
russlands präsident putin forderte die
dort verschanzten kämpfer jetzt nochmal
zur aufgabe auf man wolle den
eingeschlossenen zivilisten einen
sicheren abzug ermöglichen antoine
kurschilgen fasst die lage zusammen
wieder schwere kämpfe im stahlwerk von
mario pohl nichts zu sehen heute von
weiteren evakuierungen immerhin in der
nacht konnten mehr als 300 zivilisten
aus der belagerten hafenstadt in
sicherheit gebracht werden
vor der evakuierung wurde das stahlwerk
von der russischen luftwaffe bombardiert
wie diese bilder zeigen sollen
in mariupol konzentrieren sich die
anstrengungen der russischen besatzer
auf das stahlwerk sie versuchen weiter
unsere truppen zu zerstören
sie wollen die vollständige kontrolle
über das stahlwerk
einen erfolg meldet der ukrainische
generalstab von der südfront demnach sei
es gelungen mehrere orte zwischen person
und nikolajew zurückzuerobern eine große
gegenoffensive könne man aber erst mitte
juni starten ist es aus kiew dann wäre
die ukraine hoffentlich mehr waffen aus
dem ausland haben
schwere gefechte auch an der front im
osten hier zerstört die russische armee
offenbar gezielt brücken um westliche
waffenlieferungen zu erschweren in der
region doch jetzt steht ein öl depot in
flammen nachdem es von einer rakete
getroffen wurde
nach ukrainischen angaben sind die
eigenen truppen fordern jetzt unter
schwerem beschuss das russische militär
bombardiere auch die städte marien
körper partner und grammatik aber die
offensive im osten kommt offenbar kaum
voran
wenn es so weiter geht mit diesem tempo
und mit diesen verlusten dann ist am
ende des sommers die russische armee
zerstört dass sie keine weitere
intensive mehr führen wird können moskau
meldete heute wieder wie gewohnt
militärische erfolge die russische armee
habe hunderte ziele angegriffen und
dutzende kampffahrzeuge zerstört
sie wissen mitte april hatte die ukraine
bundespräsident steinmeier ausgeladen
und damit ein diplomatisches beben
ausgelöst heute mittag nun klingelte das
telefon im schloss bellevue am apparat
der ukrainische präsident seelands gibt
das gespräch dauerte eine dreiviertel
stunde danach ein tweet von selen ski er
schreibt hatte ein gutes konstruktives
und wichtiges gespräch mit dem deutschen
bundespräsidenten herrn steinmeier habe
mich bedankt für die starke
unterstützung der ukraine
ich erwarte dass sie noch intensiviert
wird deutsche führung ist wichtig um der
russischen aggression zu begegnen habe
ihn über die lage an der front
informiert situation in mario pohl
kritisch
wir wollen nachfragen bei theo koll in
berlin theo kanzler scholz hatte im zdf
sein nichterscheinen in der ukraine mit
der ausladung des bundespräsidenten
begründet wenn spannt sich jetzt das
verhältnis ja ich glaube ein deutliches
jahr die verknotung dürfte damit jetzt
gelöst sein das wird zwar die
grundsätzliche ukrainische kritik an der
langjährigen russland haltung
steinmeiers beziehungsweise früherer
bundesregierung und das war ja der grund
für die ausladung das wird sich glaub
ich nicht ändern aber beide seiten
wollen jetzt nach vorne schauen und in
puncto reisediplomatie ist ab sofort ja
vieles denkbar oder möglich den auftakt
macht am sonntag bundestags präsidentin
bärbel bas sie besucht kiew anlässlich
des 77 jahrestags ende zweiter weltkrieg
zeitgleich wird der bundespräsident hier
in berlin an der rede halten und ich
glaube dürfte klare worte auch zum
aktuellen krieg finden und schon am tag
danach so ist jedenfalls hier zu hören
hören dürfte sich außenminister baerbock
auf den weg nach kiew machen sie will
die deutsche botschaft wieder öffnen der
bundeskanzler hat gerade vor wenigen
minuten bestätigt dass die
außenministerin fährt reisen des
bundespräsidenten oder bundeskanzler es
nach kiew die dürften denkbar seien
jedenfalls sind sie von präsident
zielinsky jetzt beide ausdrücklich
eingeladen danke für die frischen
informationen aus berlin theo koll war
das in der ukraine sind die
kriegsschäden immens und millionen
menschen brauchen dringend hilfe viel
geld wird also gebraucht gut sechs
milliarden euro sind heute auf einer
internationalen geberkonferenz in
warschau zusammen gekommen veranstaltet
von polen und schweden mit dabei auch
die eu und die vereinten nationen
der präsident der ukraine selensky per
videoschalte dabei plädierte für eine
art marshall plan wie für den
wiederaufbau europas nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg
so schnell wie möglich versucht die
bundesregierung ja die
energieabhängigkeit von russland zu
beenden am schwierigsten wird das beim
russischen erdgas es soll jetzt nach und
nach durch lng durch liquified natural
gas also flüssig erdgas ersetzt werden
weil deutschland noch keine
entsprechende infrastruktur hat wird
jetzt in rekordzeit ein schwimmendes
terminal in wilhelmshaven gebaut heute
ging es dort also los und solche schiffe
mit hoch isolierenden tanks die werden
das lng zu uns transportieren dafür wird
normales erdgas auf minus 162 grad
herunter gekühlt um es zu verflüssigen
der entscheidende vorteil das volumen
schrumpft extrem ein kubikmeter lng
entspricht dann rund 600 kubikmetern
erdgas die größten tanker können mit
einer einzigen ladung eine stadt von
200.000 einwohnern dann fast ein jahr
mit erdgas versorgen aus wilhelmshaven
berichtet anselm stern
im norden an deutschlands küste wird
seit heute morgen gebaut für die
gaslieferungen der zukunft in
wilhelmshaven niedersachsen loben zwei
landes und ein bundesminister das turbo
projekt so schnell wie möglich sollen
hier an neu gebauten terminals die
riesentanker festmachen voll mit
flüssigerdgas voll mit der hoffnung auf
mehr energie unabhängigkeit von russland
heute kann man sagen wir haben eine gute
chance das zu schaffen was ich würde
sagen eigentlich in deutschland
unmöglich ist innerhalb von 10 monaten
etwa zehn monaten an den terminals zu
errichten und es anzuschließen haben die
deutsche gasversorgung schon im
kommenden winter also könnte lng etwa
aus den usa oder katar hier ankommen das
flüssige erdgas würde dann noch an bord
zurückverwandelt in den gast zustand und
anschließend ins netz gespeist über das
neu gebaute terminal und über neu
gebaute pipelines neben wilhelmshaven
sollen in den kommenden jahren noch drei
weitere lng standorte in deutschland
eröffnet werden
wenn man sich die deutschen terminals
anschaut die in planung sind dann werden
die eine kapazität und her schwanken die
angaben etwas
so zwischen 40 und 60 prozent der
deutschen erdgasimporte aus russland
durchaus ersetzen können raus aus
russlands exporten der wunsch und doch
gibt es enormen widerstand
umweltverbände warnen vor umweltschäden
es gab keine auslegung von unterlagen
keine beteiligung der umweltverbände
und wir befürchten massive auswirkungen
auf das wattenmeer und auf die küste
massiv ist vor allem der zeitdruck beim
thema energie die ersten lng schiffe
sollen spätestens anfang kommenden
jahres an deutschlands küste anlegen
nun ist es für verbraucher und industrie
entscheidend gas immer in ausreichender
menge zur verfügung zu haben dafür
braucht es aber vorräte auch weil die
nachfrage schwankt und um die
vorratshaltung sicherzustellen gibt es
jetzt ein neues gesetz zur zeit sind die
gasspeicher in deutschland zu 34 prozent
gefüllt das gesetz verlangt jetzt dass
der füllstand am ersten oktober bei 80
und anfang november bei 90 prozent
liegen muss so sollen wir dann alle
sicher durch die kalte jahreszeit kommen
ein problem scheint es allerdings in
niedersachsen zu geben peter kunz dazu
oberirdisch unauffällig deutschlands
größter gasspeicher in rehden in
niedersachsen unter der erde aber ist
dem hohlraum platz für so viel gas dass
zwei millionen haushalte ein jahr
versorgt wären allerdings während andere
speicher inzwischen im grünen bereich
für die jahreszeit liegen ist reden an
diesem donnerstag gerade mal zu 0,6
prozent befüllt so gut wie nichts tut
sich obwohl die bundesnetzagentur den
speicher anfang april vom russischen
betreiber in treuhand genommen sozusagen
beschlagnahmt hatte der gasspeicher
reden gehört zum gazprom germania
konzern und der gazprom germania konzern
ist ein sehr komplexer konzern mit
verschiedensten töchtern das ist alles
nicht ganz selbsterklärend und unser
generalbevollmächtigter ist jetzt gerade
dabei final zu klären wie geht das
rechtlich sauber wie geht es den
speicher schneller aufzufüllen der
sommer sollte muss dafür genutzt werden
aber aus russland wird auf die bremse
getreten der leerstand von dort gewollt
verlängert es gibt nutzer des speichers
die verträge abgeschlossen haben allem
was man weiß dass auch gesellschaft der
gastgruppe aber diese verträge sind von
der treuhänderschaft erstmal ungerührt
das heißt es ist nach der ursache des
nutzers diese speicher zu befüllen
größter vertraglicher nutzer des
speichers in reden ist nach zdf
informationen der gigant gazprom export
gesteuert aus moskau und aus der sankt
petersburger gazprom-zentrale
putins langer arm für ein störfeuer im
geschäft mit ressourcen und energie
sicherheit bis herbst muss der größte
gasspeicher deutschlands laut neuem
speichergesetz voll seien noch messen
wie bundesrepublik und die gas krake
gazprom dabei die kräfte
nach dem rassistischen terror anschlag
in hanau mit neun toten und dem rechts
terroristischen mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten lücke gab die
damalige bundesregierung unter kanzlerin
merkel eine studie in auftrag die
herausfinden sollte wie es um rassismus
in deutschland bestellt ist heute wurden
die ergebnisse präsentiert und so viel
vorweg die große mehrheit der befragten
sagt es gibt rassismus in deutschland
mehr von heike slansky
es sind die alltäglichen geschichten die
hier gehört werden ob hautfarbe kopftuch
oder name anders für vorurteile wie ein
berliner beispiel zeigt die damalige
vermieterin einer frau mit einem
arabischen nachnamen hat den namen
eigenmächtig am klingelschild geändert
mit der begründung ihr nachname würde zu
touristisch kling laut einer studie
vorgestellt von der neuen
familienministerin glauben 90 prozent
der befragten das ist rassismus gibt
rassismus in deutschland das gibt es
eben nicht nur am rand der gesellschaft
wir müssen uns vielmehr immer wieder
bewusst machen rassismus gibt es überall
es mitten unter uns laut nationalem
diskriminierung und rassismus monitor
haben 22 prozent der 5000 befragten
selbst schon rassismus erfahren 65
prozent meinen dass es in behörden
rassistische diskriminierung gibt
dagegen bezeichnen 45 prozent rassismus
kritik als übertrieben erstaunt hat die
forscher dass jeder zweite immerhin noch
glaubt dass es unterschiedliche rassen
gäbe wenn genetischen gefunden seit den
70er jahren schon klar ist es gibt keine
menschenrassen dann haben wir
offensichtlich im biologieunterricht
noch einiges nachzuholen ein
umfangreicher bericht über ursachen
ausmaß und folgen von rassismus
rassismus führt zu unsicherheit
rassismus für zu angst bei betroffenen
er führt dazu dass menschen bestimmten
wohngegenden meiden den erkenntnissen
müssen nun taten folgen immerhin sind
laut studie 70 prozent bereit sich gegen
rassismus zu engagieren
viele weitere fakten aus der rassismus
studie haben wir online für sie
zusammengefasst etwa wie menschen
hierzulande rassismus erleben und wie
sie dazu stehen dass alles in unserer
zdf heute app
dass wirecard desaster beschäftigt auch
die gerichte und jetzt gibt es ein
erstes urteil die bilanzen des einstigen
börsenstars waren schon 2017 und 2018
falsch so das münchner landgericht in
erster instanz und das bedeutet die
aktionäre müssen die dividenden die es
eigentlich gar nicht hätte geben dürfen
an den insolvenzverwalter zurückzahlen
47 millionen euro und die chancen für
schadensersatzklagen gegen die
zuständigen wirtschaftsprüfer steigen
denn die hatten die bilanzen damals für
korrekt erklärt jetzt zu einer krankheit
die kinder eigentlich fast nie bekommen
hepatitis also eine entzündung der leber
seit ein paar wochen registrieren ärzte
weltweit eine häufung insgesamt meldet
die weltgesundheitsorganisation
228 fälle die in 20 ländern auftraten
vier kinder starben auffällig ist die
klassischen hepatitis e erreger konnten
in keinem der fälle nachgewiesen werden
rund zwei drittel aller kinder
erkrankten in großbritannien und von
dort berichtet jetzt andreas stamm
ständiges erbrechen die sorge wuchs mit
jeder stunde lieber ins krankenhaus
dachten sich im julias eltern nach
sieben tagen klinik ging es der
zweijährigen besser die ursache unklar
hepatitis daran denkt niemand zurück zu
hause wird es wirklich ernst
plötzlich traten anzeichen von gelbsucht
auf elias haut verfärbte sich man konnte
es in ihren augen sehen aber sie spielte
weiter bei ansonsten wie immer die
gewebeentnahme zeigt akute
leberentzündung ein test auf adenoviren
ist positiv die verursachen
normalerweise erkältungen oder durchfall
stehen nun aber im verdacht die
mysteriöse häufung von hepatitis bei
kindern auszulösen da das virus in
britannien etwa bei rund 80 prozent der
bislang 140 fälle nachgewiesen wurde
es könnte sich um eine aggressivere
variante des adenovirus handeln oder
daran liegen dass viele kinder durch
lange zeiten der isolation während der
lok downs ein schwächeres immunsystem
besitzen eine dritte möglichkeit wäre
dass eine corona infektion die
widerstandsfähigkeit des immunsystems
verändert hat
[Musik]
keiner der britischen fälle war geimpft
dass scheider als erklärung aus in
deutschland gab es bislang einen dieser
nicht erklärbaren hepatitis erkrankungen
in england ist das sicherlich etwas was
wir mit sorge beobachten wird das in
deutschland auch kommen eine hypothese
ist ja spielt saß da eine rolle es ist
sehr unwahrscheinlich meiner meinung
nach aber die engländer sind auch in
ihrer epidemie einige monate vor uns und
deswegen beobachten wir den sommer hier
sein rat an die eltern wachsam sein aber
kein grund zur panik um das rätsel zu
lösen brauche es zeit die auch emilia
braucht ein paar wochen wird es dauern
so die ärzte bis sie wieder 100 prozent
fit ist
sechs arbeitsreiche monate auf der iss
liegen hinter ihm inzwischen ist der
astronaut matthias maurer auf dem
rückweg zur erde in den vergangenen
wochen experimentierte er mit wasser in
der schwerelosigkeit er absolvierte
einen außeneinsatz und feierte mit
seinen russischen und us kolleginnen und
kollegen geburtstag morgen früh soll
seine dragon kapsel im meer vor florida
lang
und sie können quasi dabei sein sagt er
heute live überträgt die landung ab 6
uhr 15 so und jetzt zu den fußball kann
christ ich absolut sehr gern zuerst die
champions league das finale der
königsklasse steht fest wie schon 2018
treffen ende mai den fc liverpool und
real madrid in paris aufeinander die
königlichen kamen dank ihres unbändigen
kampfgeist und das erneut überragenden
karim benzema weiter
analog oder ein wahnsinn skandieren die
fans nach einem wahren fußball drama
dass ihnen ihre helden geschenkt haben
der manchester nach 73 minuten durch war
es in führung geht ist die entscheidung
gegen madrid eigentlich schon gefallen
für das was sich dann durch zwei späte
tore des eingewechselten rodrigo
abspielt hat selbst reals welt
erfahrener trainer ancelotti keine worte
dieses spiel ist auch für mich
unerklärlich sie max gabel dass sich
karim benzema in der verlängerung im
strafraum fallen lässt und den strafstoß
höchstselbst zum 3 1 endstand verwandelt
macht aus diesem fußballspiel in madrid
wie gesagt einen wahnsinn hurra
und vielleicht heute abend erneut und
nachher treffen nämlich parallel gleich
zwei deutschen vereinen dicke und die
haben die große chance ins endspiel der
europa league einzuziehen eher beleibt
sich bei den glasgow rangers und
eintracht frankfurt empfängt west ham
united
die eintracht will sich nicht verstecken
das kann man deutlich sehen und alle
bälle liegen ja sowieso auf frankfurter
seite aus dem 2 1 hinspielsieg bei west
ham soll aber kein ruhekissen fürs
rückspiel werden
unsere herangehensweise ist klar er habe
das den spielern jetzt auch schon
gestern und heute gesagt dass das in
unseren köpfen ist dass wir hier auf
sieg spielen zu hause von der ersten
sekunde an mit unseren fans im rücken
das wir hier jetzt nicht irgendetwas
verwalten und schauen wir mal sondern
ganz klare marschroute ist nach vorne zu
spielen die leipziger sind auswärts in
glasgow anders gefordert über den gewinn
der europa league könnte doch die
champions league erreicht werden trotz
des 1 0 erfolgs im hinspiel sinnt sie
auf tore aus davon gehe ich aus weil
die rangers entsprechend druck machen
werden vielleicht nicht von ganz anfang
an vielleicht aber auch doch und tore
schießen ist immer ein gutes rezept
50.000 zuschauer werden in glasgow
erwartet macht es nicht einfacher für
leipzig am schluss 21 uhr du schaust 1
spielt ich tippe auf ein
deutsch-deutsches sie war gut danke
christin zum wetter so viel es wird
etwas wärmer details gleich von post
intelli um 21.45 sei ihnen christian
sievers und das heute-journal ans herz
gelegt dass heute 19 team bedankt sich
für das einschalten wir sehen uns morgen
wieder machen sie sich noch einen
entspannten abend
angesprochen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter zwischen
zwei hochs einmal über westeuropa und
weiter im osten hängt ein tief über der
mittelmeerregion und schiebt hier
feucht-warme luft zu uns und so gibt es
an den alpen in deutschland dann auch
schauer und gewitter sonst bleibt es
trocken schauen wir uns die details an
dem süden also kompakte wolken teils mit
regen sonst klart es auf teilweise
bildet sich nebel in der nähe von
flüssen und das bei temperaturen von 3
grad in der norddeutschen tiefebene das
ist der tiefste wert der kommenden acht
und zehn grad zum beispiel richtung
bayern morgen daran tagesverlauf ganz im
süden südlich der donau schauer und
gewitter auch kompakte wolken dabei
sonst aber überwiegend aufgelockerte
bewölkung mit sonnenschein bei höchsten
temperaturen von 14 grad an den alpen
und der höchste wert 23 grad im rhein
main gebiet aber häufig temperaturen um
die 20 grad marke
die nächsten tage am samstag noch einige
schauer die durchziehen das wird nicht
viel sein auch im süden 14 bis 23 grad
und danach steigen die temperaturen es
gibt zwar noch eine schauer und
gewitterneigung aber zum montag wird es
trockener dann sogar bis 25 grad ein
schöner abend